thank you
yeah so
uh sorry for the early starting today
i actually changed my slides because
yesterday leihan put
pushed me to talk about syrian
applications so somehow this is now the
title appeared in on the website and
what i'm going to show is uh
this kind of a structure basically
what's the heart theory and actually
legend get very
basic level elementary introduction
about that so here i would like to point
out
uh the
linear algebraic version of hot series
together with various
various kind of
pictures appeared in literature and
the most focus will be on combinatorial
heart theory uh simplistic complex that
will be used for various kind of
applications well in particular i will
show some applications from computer
vision statistical ranking and game
theory so that's the basic structure of
today's talk
and
suppose
you might remember
in your multi-varied calculus course
some a theorem like this this is called
helmholtz decomposition means given any
vector field on a simply connected
domain d
and it can be uniquely decomposed in
this form the first line is called
divergence-free flow basically it's a
kind of cyclic
flow or cyclic vector field the second
is called the gradient field
which basically starting from somewhere
and ending with
two somewhere and so this kind of looks
like a potential gradient so this
decomposition actually happens on the
plane with simple
connected domain means that there's no
holes in the domain and this picture
actually coming from the gerald marston
who passed a few years ago and torrents
a classic book on fluid mechanics but
you probably wonder what's the
essence
elements in this hot series so i just
give you one particular picture in terms
of linear algebra language so you don't
need to worry about anything beyond
linear algebra suppose you just have
three inner product space x y and z and
we have two
operators or two matrices a acting from
x to y b acting from y to z and this
composition satisfy this particular rule
the
a followed by b must be equals to zero
that's the only constraint we are going
to use and we can define a laplacian
operator like
this uh acting from y to y
basically you come from this direction
go a a joint because vector in the
product space you can always define a
drawing operator so from a or join to a
and pull back here in another direction
b and b are joined then come back so
this kind of abstract laplacian operator
will be defined in this way so whenever
you have this kind of condition you can
show by linear algebra language the
middle
inner product space y always admits this
orthogonal decomposition this is
canonical
basically image of a plus kernel of this
laplacian operator and the plus image b
star so that's the hard decomposition so
a virus kind of language can be
associated with this type of
decomposition you can call homology
group or co-homology group depending on
what kind of the domain uh the field uh
the model you are going to use to define
the vector space and in the product
space so i won't yes the legend give you
a very
comprehensive list of various names can
be
algebraic topology
theory names but here i just give you
the one answer how to prove this a
simple theorem so this one turns out to
be equivalent to the rank analytic
theorem in
in linear algebra you don't need to
worry about too much and
this
to use rank analytics theorem to prove
the hard theory basically you can define
a
hot a big space take all the xyz as a
product and a big operator which
consists of a and b in the up lower
diagonal and all the other parts equals
to zero and together with this
important constraint b followed by a
followed by b must vanishes and
laplacian we can define a high
dimensional laplace and make all this
stack everything together
we take d plus d star and take square of
that so the d this operator in physics
sometimes we call the dirac operator but
this is just a very interesting matrix
if you take this uh d plus d star square
then you get this diagonal matrix this
diagonal matrix the first part
the first element will be a operator
only acting on x the self action and the
second part is a operator acting on y
and the third part will be on z and if
you are
careful enough you can see uh when later
when we develop one dimensional
hydrologist this sometimes called a
graph laplace this one sometimes called
one dimensional heart laplacian and this
one can be used two-dimensional by the
lower part or down part
of how to divisor but this you can't
forget this kind of sorry
you can't ignore that
okay
ignore this part for the moment
and
these three lines just prove the hard
decomposition using rank analytic
theorem
consider this matrix the image of this
matrix plus the kernel of its joint must
equals to the whole space v then if we
restrict everything onto the middle y
what will happen so in the middle y the
image of d
implied by the image of a so you take
image of a here and a kernel of these
transpose this star
this one
appeared here will be kernel of ace
trans star and
this kernel of a star because we know a
b this composition must equal to zero so
image of a must lies in the kernel of b
then
another direction kernel of a star must
include kernel image of b star so if you
replic you plug in this term decompose
this kernel a star further into two
orthogonal subspace one is image b star
another it's complement orthogonal
complement then in the middle you
can
replace this condition by the kernel of
b star basically the intersection of
kernel
a star and kernel b this one give the
this quotient space so somehow from here
you can see the previous slide
because it's a kernel must equals to the
abstract
laplacian and so in the middle this
laplacian kernel so you can put it here
so this is the rank analytics theorem
derivation for the heart decomposition
so if you are curious
what's the
linear algebra element behind that so
you basically you can follow this simple
scheme
and
now this simple linear algebra can carry
various kind of a structure in terms of
different settings the first version of
a heart series coming from a remaining
manifold if you started the ram
complex
basically you study the chain map
becomes those x1 y and z those in the
product space becomes the k differential
forms on the manifold and the
operator a and b those operator becomes
exterior derivative operator and then
you can define this kind of a complex we
call it the ram complex and the hot
composition naturally follows what we
described before
and another version is very recent to uh
work by
steve smile and his collaborators so he
they started the metric space and hodge
decomposition structure now the
differential form becomes the square
integral functions of matrix space x and
you can put finite difference operator
which often used in numerical analysis
and data analysis and from low order to
high order defined in this way and you
can define a joint operator basically
they are the integral operator and
follow this direction then you can also
find the d square mass equals to zeros
and the heart decomposition the algebra
naturally carries here
so the third version is what i'm going
to use in the virus kind of application
below is a finite version of a
combinatorial hardware
theory basically we study a set finite
set x and we build up a simplistic
complex abstract and pluto complex from
x that means we take a subset collection
from x and if any set at all lies in the
collection then all its subset must be
also included in the collection we call
this property as include closeness under
the inclusion or deletion and when this
satisfied we form a simplistic complex
then you can define the k forms as a
alternating functions satisfying taking
any permutation on the index set you get
a sign of depending on the audit of the
permutation and then it satisfies this
kind of symmetry condition and the code
boundary map still is the kind of
alternating difference operator
similarly you can define it's a joint
and now if we take one particular
example consider a graph we have a
undirected graph but you can put
orientation on the simplex on the edge
and you can blow up the graph into a
click complex scene you could collect
all the complete subra from the from g
then you form a collection this
collection satisfy the closeness and the
deletion the property then becomes a
simplistic complex then with k-forms you
can define something like that for zero
form basically it's a function on the
vertex set for one form it's a skill
symmetric functions defined on pairwise
vertex you can on the oriented edges and
the two forms basically are triangular
curl it satisfy this kind of alternating
symmetry uh then you you define the
function on the oriented triangles so co
boundary operator basically just
difference operators and if you take a
map from
zero form to one form that forms the
finite difference operator on the graph
if you take a
from one form to
two forms then basically you take a
triangular trace along the orientation
of the triangle basically depending on
the orientation you can put plus or
minus sign there we call this a kind of
operator as curve and similarly if you
define the
inner product natural euclidean inner
product or anything associated with this
form you can make a joint operator of
them and
the most important property is a curl of
of gradient field must equal to zero so
this kind you can understand it from
very basic
multivariate calculus and a
one-dimensional combinatorial laplacian
will be defined in the abstract like
this and
in particular if k equal to zero that
becomes the graph laplacian but if you
get a k equal to one the one-dimensional
heart laplacian will be very useful in
the later development like
game series decomposition and the
ranking decomposition and these are
things are the same as before the linear
algebra part the useful things that i
why this kind of structure uh repeatedly
used in
from manifold to modern data analysis
because
reminding manifold and metric space and
cell complex whenever you forget some
structure
like a matrix structure
differentiability structure but
everything environment
preserved with this kind of linear
algebra and that reflects some
topological environments like a homology
reflected in the dimension of kernel of
laplacian so
we don't need those super high
sophisticated structure but with cell
complex very natural
fitting for data analysis so we expect
this kind of
property may make hard theory in appear
in virus kind of
applications so the classical
application for heart decomposition is
bound
value problem in pde and very recently
there appears a lot of new applications
from computer vision and to sensor
network coverage and statistical ranking
and the finite game decomposition so i
will pick some of them to illustrate how
the idea might be used in various
different kind of setting so the
in computer vision a very well-known
model called the rooting ocean phetamine
model they study piecewise constant flow
approximation given a
kind of uh
uh a given image on the on the plane
for example on two dimensional plane and
uh
the piecewise constant flow basically
represented by the total variation
regularization term this one basically a
l1
norm for if you take
this
one as a group as a complex
number in the plane
on the other in other language like
statistics they can call it a group
lasso and so this one favors a piecewise
constant flow but why we have to use a
total variation as to use piecewise
constant flow to approximate original
image the the intuition is a piecewise
constant flow may help you to preserve
the edge in the image however if the
flow
if the original image coming from videos
or
image sequences there are often some
objects in the videos and the object may
undergo certain
movement so in that case piecewise
constant flow may not be a good uh
regularization to preserve the
object
uh
the edges associated with objects so
recently people suggest use a piecewise
harmonic flow to approximate original
line and this one becomes a useful to
study the optical
flow problem in the
video processing so here is not quite
clear to you but basically it says that
there are some objects in the receptive
field and the object undergoes some
rotation
movement and if you use a piecewise
constant flow then you totally
broke the broken object boundary but if
you use a harmonic piecewise harmonic
flow then that very adaptive to the
objects so illustrate this kind of
application another application from
computer vision so this example called
adolescence illusion for example if you
put a pillow a column on the chessboard
and
the pro the column leave you some shade
on the board so basically there are two
colors white and black but under the
shading the absolute intensity inside of
the
shade
will
make the white
white part looks like the black part
outside of the shade so this is the
illustrate so this black part has
absolute intensity level at the same
level as this
white part inside the shade but
although this one happened
to be the same of intensity level for
you you never get confused this is a
white this is
not white but this should be black this
is white you never get confused with
these two how this happened in for human
eyes and
people suggest because human eyes only
use the sorry
quick question so you mentioned the cell
complex earlier so are these strategical
as arbitrary cell contactors or as ones
embedded in some dimensional like other
abstract
abstract yeah it can be abstract it can
be embedded
yeah
and
and for this version and people suggest
to use a pairwise contrast
to
to reconstruct the image that means that
we look at the vector field derived from
the gradient of the original image and
then use a
truncated version to remove the noise
then reconstruct using some sparse
reconstruction so this kind of approach
uh suggested by osha sometimes it can be
related to heart decomposition but it
may not be out to the version heart
decomposition so if you are curious
maybe you can sing from this kind of
direction
so this second example is from
computerization the third example
actually
is from a multimedia society a small
society within the computer vision and
people wanna wonder you have lots of
videos on the youtube for example
facebook you have lots of pictures and
those multimedia content
may be the same but
company need want to know if we adopt
certain uh data compression technology
and how the radio content content looks
good or bad for the reviewers for the
cloud on the internet so basically they
adopt the crowd sourcing quality of
experience experiment try to evaluate
how the technology
looks good or bad so this is kind of
another resource for power's comparison
with a crowd sourcing experiment
emerged recently and
this particular example from computer
vision called the learning relative
attribute given a pair of a given a face
from the internet and you are asked a
question how old this
people looks like it's very difficult
for you to give any answer how old but
if you are given a pair of images then
relatively you are easy to tell which
one looks older
which one looks younger so this kind of
application
we use a relative we call the relative
attribute and age is only one example
and the people adopt a pairwise
comparisons and from to collect the data
using cloud sourcing platform on the
internet so
all these kind of data
kind of give you this kind of abstract
problem you are given a graph with the
vertex set
those alternatives to be ranked or
compared and the ad set consists a
large number of pairwise comparisons and
people different people may vote
different pairs and hear some different
color and
if you trace back to the classical page
rank that's the one particular version
for this uh for this kind of data but
more data nowadays
arise from
multimedia and computer vision and the
human wine test
psychology study and this kind of data
how to aggregate uh into a consistent
global preference order or global
ranking this is very classical problem
if you can trace back to the
social choice theory
so it starts from the 18th century and
the people know that at that time
majority voting may arise some
inconsistency and especially arrows
impossibility serum says that if you
follow the majority voting then all the
kind of
ranking chaos may happen otherwise
except you take a a
monopoly structure in the fine social
society rule but various kind of
interpretation for arrows impossibility
theorem but
in practice people still use a
statistical majority voting and the
question is how much you can
gain from impossibility you how possible
you can do that with that and
so here is a from statistical society
people can aggregate pairwise comparison
using various kind of models depending
whether the data is a preference degree
or binary choice you can choose various
kind of models and all these models give
you kind of a abstract data you have a
pairwise comparison data which
lies on the edge space and which has
square integral in the certain sense and
with certain inner product defined by
the
confidence level
so
uh if you have such kind of data the
hard decomposition basically tells you
this one
any kind of data coming from the
stochastic majority voting admits such a
orthogonal decomposition and the first
component which is a gradient of certain
scaling function on the vertex side
second the component actually satisfies
this triangular curl
equal to zero and
simultaneously it has to satisfy the
divergence with equals to zero we call
it curl free and divergence free and
these two conditions uniquely decide the
uh signal com the projection component
here and in other words if you put that
into a large decomposition means such
kind of data always has this kind of
heart decomposition the question is
how can we find these each of the
components the first component actually
basically solved the graph last equation
and satisfying this one and the good
news is
recently people know that for those
graph laplacian equation we have nearly
linear algorithm but
means
there are kind of suggestions from a
society
like us billman and tom and gary
miller's group they try to make this
kind of algorithm more practical in
their
practice
but the
third part coming from the second part
so how to compute the harmonic and the
curl part so this is a
kind of difficult
so what's the meaning of these two parts
for the
third part curl part actually it
accounts for local inconsistencies i
call because
on every triangle the total
curve should
should not vanish but
the middle part is kind of tricky
because it satisfies both
triangular
curl free and the divergence frame
basically it gives you a circular
ranking
we call the harmonic ranking and this
kind of circular ranking that
generically will pass all the voltage
set so give you a tot
total round outer and on those vertex
sets so this one creates all the chaotic
voting results once you have any
component like this so this is probably
the hardest part in ranking
but the question is how to compute them
and
people may think that the code path
seems easier to solve because every hot
laplacian has the upper one and lower
one
talked by leihan and cheyenne and you
can solve this upper one solely when you
get a projection on the coil part but
the question is uh the upper part in
terms of the pos
in terms of graph laplacian kind of uh
progress the third the
uh this is a
co-part equation it's not that easy
because this one is far from
far away from the
being
diagonal dominant in fact if you look at
the performance risky curvature defined
for the hot laplacian the form that
means if this quantity is negative for
every edge then this one laplacian must
be diagonal dominance this is a kind of
equivalent condition for the
one laplacian to be diagonal dominance
so we know if the laplacian is diagonal
dominance this although it's one
laplacian we can always
convert this laplacian to be some graph
laplacian using some two color covering
and then you can follow the previous
technique for graph laplacian equation
solve it
efficiently that means that we can find
harmonic ranking much more easily in
this case but in general
we if it is not diagonal dominance
things might be harder but the question
why the upper part is
might be harder to solve than the whole
one laplacian because if you look at
upper part it's a risky curvature is
always smaller than the
total
the whole
one laplacian part so that means it
tends to be more negative
than the diagonal dominance y so this
one is if you pursue the diagonal
dominance kind of uh technique for
perhaps this upper part is much harder
to solve so i'm not sure whether this is
a good
reason to persuade you
to move to harmonic ranking computation
rather than the co computation but
there are a lot of things inside this
kind of question may be considered
and the topological obstructions in hot
decomposition because it relies on the
connectivity and whether there is a bt-1
loop in the [ __ ] complex so
if uh the
if the
uh the
check the complete complex gen uh
created from the graph
uh is connected then we can get a global
ranking up to a translation constant and
if it is a further loop free then every
harmonic you don't have any uh
trivial harmonic ranking then you won't
have this kind of circular coordinates
which creates all the
voting chaos so how to
track
the topology change so basically we have
using the persistent homology we can
have a polynomial algorithm up to number
of
cells or simplex in the simplest complex
up to the power two point something it
depends on uh
future development and basically you can
use this kind of algorithm to do the uh
it gives an online algorithm for
topology tracking if the simplex
sequentially enters the stream
and the wireless kind of problem when in
hard run when you try to apply it for
cross sourcing study and i just listed
some of them first important thing is
how to design sampling scheme and so
here you can use random graph theory to
guide your study and the second thing is
how much reliability how to deal with
the reliability of data and we can
develop outlier detection and robust
ranking and the third one is how to face
the streaming data
you need some online algorithm i won't
talk too much about
these things and if you are interested
you can look at those references which
appeared in our collaborators and
some
some people in osha's team recently
so
so here i would like to give you another
application so this is one of my
favorite examples of hot decomposition
applications
so
you can use hard conversation to study
finite games in fact every finite game
animates such
can be decomposed into
the harsh structure that correspond to
zero sum and potential game very well
studied
topics in game theory so if we look uh
look look uh how how to convert the data
game data into the
hodge decomposition structure basically
you can look at the
uh other standard form for the normal
form of the game so for example here is
the battle of the sexist
game so you have two uh person wife and
husband and each one has two options in
the weekend to choose whether they go go
to the see the opera or they go to see
the football and if the husband
and wife
both go to the opera then the wife will
be more satisfied but husband will be a
little bit less satisfied and on the
opposite if both go to see the football
the husband will be much happier than
the wife and
the sad thing is one go to see opera
another go to football and depending on
whether the husband like the opera or
the wife likes the football the number
can various but you can put
such a buy made such matrix as the
payout function for each of the player
so the question is uh we need to make a
graph representing this game the graph
basically consists all the vertex sets
as the
each play all the you how the player put
their strategy as a vector then put the
vector profile a strategy profile as a
node then you make up a large graph each
node represents the strategy profile and
how to put edge between the notes so
one choice suggested by a pablo paridos
group is
if only one player change their strategy
then you use a edge
add edge between them so that means the
two strategy
profiles are comparable if
only if two
strat only one user change strategy
because in that particular case you can
use that particular user utility as the
edge flow so that maps the data on the
graph in the this fault
in this way so
if you take a
such a
such a data basically you find
you can
you can preserve the nash and the
correlated equilibrium with respect to
this kind of
data
graph flow data and
suppose you have a joint distribution on
the strategy profile
space and which is basically uh per uh
tensor uh uh depends on the how many
players have you have a high order
tensor and if it satisfy this kind of
linear inequality then this tensor must
be
equilibrium and in literature often call
this one as correlated equilibrium and
if you take a rank one tensor if this
one is rank one means every player
independently choose their strategy
satisfying the same set of linear
equations then that's called nash
equilibrium and both equilibrium
actually can be fully decided by the
edge flow data when we map the game onto
the graph in this way we don't lose any
information about
about the equilibrium problem
and the question is uh what which
equilibrium we should look at so this is
very complicated problem in game theory
people mostly look at the nash
equilibrium but in reality p the
performance suggests equal correlated
equilibrium because they think
people never
decide make decisions in the fully
independent in reality so
people may players some maybe
decisions may be influenced by its
relatives and maybe it's close friend
and so based certain decision or process
may happen in the
in the reality so he suggests correlated
equilibrium may be more suitable to
study than this kind of nash equilibrium
fully independent case but
another reason is finding nash
equilibriums notoriously np-hat you need
to solve polynomial equations but
if you just look at a correlated
equilibrium finding a single correlated
equilibrium is a linear programming
relatively easy especially for graphical
games and
some natural learning process may
converge to correlated equilibrium but
now the nash equilibrium so these kind
of reasons suggest people to consider
correlated equilibrium more than nash
equilibrium but the question is can we
benefit from this kind of uh situation
to see whether uh nash we can find the
nash equilibrium through this kind of
uh structure actually correlative
equilibrium contains the convex how of
the nash equilibrium it's a negative
tensor uh rank one uh or rank two of uh
small rank depending on the number of
nash equilibrium in the set
largely scaled in that
than that number but
if a tensor is rank 2
then we know
all the if and only if all its matrix
flattenings are run at most two so that
means if you have a tensor
at most of rank two you can easily just
look at all its matrix flattening use a
matrix linear algebra like pc like as we
did to find such low rank tensor however
if you look at the negative tensor
if it is as negative rank at most two
then you need both rank and most matrix
flattening rank at most two and super
modular so this situation makes things
harder so
can we find low rank negative tensor
approximation given the linear
inequality constraints this this is a
kind of interesting question suggested
from uh
if we look at the data
if we look at the
data from this point of view
and
another kind of direction for
simplification of games is kind of
graphical games that means that we have
a un-player live on the network of nodes
and every player has utility only depend
on its neighbor players
this kind of constraint leave you a
joint distribution factorization in the
in this product way it's not rank one
factorization but low order interaction
depending on the neighborhood size so
you basically can restrict your factor
each factor on the clique maximal clique
of the
on the on the graph so this one can
reduce uh for
uh double exponential complexity of
representation for this joint
distribution to
x double exponential to neighborhood
maximize neighborhood size and we hope
to have a polynomial correlated
polynomial algorithm to find correlated
equilibrium in some simple graph like
trees and charter graphs so this kind of
a
structure and no matter which one
before and we find uh actually uh pablo
parillo recently suggested every finite
game admits a unique decomposition means
uh
the data we when we map to the graph
flow always decompose into as a
potential game and harmonic game and the
risk neutral game districts neutral game
means every
player can translate their utility
by a constant and doesn't change their
relative
preference
but this one will lead to this neutral
games but the other two will be much
more important because a potential game
and harmonic game
both might be easier to solve in
literature so uh if you consider the
sharpie mandatory condition in game
theory actually every potential game if
and every game is a potential game if
and only if every triangular curve
equals to zero vanishes so you can
further decompose this potential game by
adding quadrangular cells rather than
triangular cells in this game case a
harmonic game can be further decomposed
into quadrangle curl games in that way
you can localize the game and make the
uh
harmonic part much more localized and
this may give you another kind of
way to look at the game decomposition so
in particular if you look at biomatrix
game like the example we proposed in the
beginning
for the battle sex such game always uh
decided by uh potent potential game by
the symmetric part of this biomatrix one
and the harmonic game is by decided by
the skew symmetric part and
these parts are very easy to solve
because a
symmetrical part all the pure notch
equilibrium just decided by the local
maximum and correlated equilibrium will
be the complex time of such a maximum
and a harmonic theme actually no pure
natural equilibrium appear only makes
nash equilibrium and what's the benefit
if you decompose game into this way
because uh if
uh each of them the potential of zero
sum each of them will be tractable
however their direct sum is not
tractable is very np hard in the worst
case
but if your game is
close to a potential game then you can
easily achieve the
approximately nash equilibrium
in this case but on the other hand we
don't know if it is close to harmonic
what's the usage
what's the benefit can we bend we can
obtain from such a decomposition
so this is a
kind of application for
game theory and
so
as a summary i basically mostly cover
focus on the statistical ranking and
every
such pairwise comparison data can be
mapped to gradient flow harmonic flow
and curve flow and comparably in game
theory you get a potential game and
harmonic game
why curl doesn't appear because you use
a click a triangle click suggested by
originally by pablo paredo but if you
look at the quadrangle cells and map
them in uh put them into the
cell simplicity complex and you get a
quadrangle curve flow so this kind of
thing may help you
to find the equilibrium and
make some settings that you can get
tractable another application in
computer vision we hope to find more in
the future so hopefully this kind of uh
introduction does not make you to feel
too much boring with hot decomposition
personally i like this structure very
much
although it's simple but it appears in
from very deep
algebraic topology to very simple linear
algebra so thank you
for your listening and these are my
collaborators and friends
any questions
couple questions yeah so um when you do
the um
uh so when you want to get the uh i'm
only free ranking
yeah is it
simply a matter of just adding all
triangular faces so you just don't have
any holes to start with so actually the
original suggestion by pablo is he only
use triangular faces actually he put
because every player can change his
strategy arbitrarily then whenever he
change it to a triangle then he put a
triangular face there but
the
sharply mandara serum actually trace the
curl along every quadrangle so you can
extend the faces from triangular to
quadrangle by adding all the quadrangle
in that case you can reproduce the
sharpie mandara serum and then localize
the harmonic
decomposition harmonic game to those
quadrangular code game so maybe that's
useful if the code is really localized
because typically harmonic game is a
global cycle along all the
strategy profiles
okay
thanks again